police fired rubber bullets and tear gas
to disperse Stone throwing opposition
crowds blocking major intersection roads
in the capital Dhaka many opposition
activists and leaders were beaten up by
the police and hundreds were detained
opposition blames the government for the
Crackdown
We are following the Democratic ways for
a peaceful event we are conducting our
event with the people and our supporters
they may beat us but we will stay strong
in our demands We are following the path
of ideals and righteousness
the government said the programs by
opposition parties are intended to
destabilize the country and make people
suffer the ruling Army League party said
it will stage a demonstration across the
country on Sunday protesting the
violence Unleashed by the opposition
party
as we are in power we are the Sentinels
of the general Public's Safety and
Security that is why we took a position
on the streets today by order of the
Prime Minister therefore nobody can play
with people's lives and fire there has
been series of rallies and marches by
the main opposition and its Alliance
parties in recent weeks they all
demanded the resignation of the
government they say the last two
elections were fraudulent many people
are also angry at the government for
failing to stop restoring energy and
food prices right now we are desperately
waiting to get the free
and credible election to hold the Free
Fair credible and participatory election
there is no alternative without
establishing
caretaker or interim government Western
Nations led by the United States and the
United Nations have been pressing
Bangladesh on its human rights record
and calling for free and fair elections
the situation right now is coming the
capital city but people are anxious they
expect more unrest and protest in coming
weeks and months ahead of the general
election
for now security has been tightened
across the country with many fearing the
wars is yet to come so chaudry Al
Jazeera Dhaka
foreign